[Music]
your partner the all athletes season how
you feeling I'm feeling great you know
she's amazing and we had a couple of
rehearsals she's super busy and
schedules really really tight she's in
school but it's great it's gonna be
great season you know it's very short
it's very different all athletes gonna
be super competitive so you know all
depends on the vote sole defense of the
public they got a two name both for us
team mera ballers this shortened
schedule only four weeks it's crazy does
that heighten things are you changing
anything about what you do being on a
tighter schedule I mean it feels like
we're actually going to week seven you
know it's only week four or four weeks
and two coffins go home every week it's
gonna be crazy you know this is the
first time we usually have Monday no one
gets eliminated we're going to next week
kind of like you know pace yourself
take it easy and don't throw all the
tricks and everything in the week one
but this is going to be you know such a
short season that it would have to push
it so hard and do everything is possible
not to go home I remember seeing you
guys here last year and you were I think
very pregnant at this event last year
yes do you get to have a date night out
like have a glass of wine tonight relax
a little bit today it's gonna be the
night we're so excited driving here
we're like talking about it I'm you're
like it's great actually
have a little night together I love it
how do you guys kind of keep that spark
going because you're so busy and you've
got the kids I know you're super
family-oriented but is it date night
what's your secret to stay in sexy and
romantic well every time I'm in town you
know cuz I'm rehearsing South Bend
Indiana and every time I'm in town I'm
like let's go out for a dinner or drinks
you know have at least like a day a week
last question I mean having gotten to
know your partner a little bit now how
is her natural dancing ability what are
you working on with her and what are you
prepping for the first dance
she's a great basketball player you know
she's not a dancer period but she's got
the rhythm she's got great musicality
she feels the music she can keep the
timing this is the most important thing
you know and again like loosen up a
little bit get those hips moving and
I'll be fine
what are you prepping for the first
dance we're doing salsa what do you
consider your biggest competition I
think the biggest competition is ice
skaters all of them are like damn I
three of them in there but again you
know all athletes are super competitive
you know I'm sure they know how to work
hard you know they have a huge careers
behind them and that's gonna help them
to achieve the goal you know to prep
because it's you know it's kind of a
sport you know Dancing's kind of sport
twice a lot of physical energy but my
partner is great you know she's very
strong she's very focused she works
really hard she wants to learn how to
dance
[Music]